you know we've spoken about highlander
for maybe
five years now i mean
it's been a really long time do you do
you have a script on highlander that
you're really happy with or are you
still tweaking it
we're still we're in the process of
tweaking right now i think we
think we know what we want more
importantly than anything we know we
want to make
it's in the creatives we know we're
trying to make it's just a matter of
getting it to the point where we feel
okay this is let's go
but we're we're closer than we've ever
been so that's good
do you have in your brain uh your ideal
casting for highlander or have you not
even allowed yourself to like open that
door yet oh no i like you know i'm a
in the in the vision in my head like you
know i've always loved henry cavill so
like you know i mean he's
he's one of my big choices i think have
you and pardon me for knowing but have
you actually
have you reached out to him does he
we've spoken several times yeah i mean i
could be wrong about this but hasn't
this come out that you guys have [ __ ]
yeah yeah it came out about a year ago
yeah i was gonna say i mean i i feel
like i knew that um listen i think
henry's super talented i think he i can
do something and i think him and i can
do something but they haven't seen him
so it's not just about muscles and
brooding i think he he's got an
incredible range and i think he'd bring
something very special and his
enthusiasm has been amazing in it so
yeah the other thing is he has a little
bit of training with the sword on
witcher a little bit yeah he's pretty
good
you